you're doing ok good buddy calls press
are not a silencer your ears I mean
rings so loud Oh a lot of things that
get wrong it's crazy out there man the
power just went out everybody starts
talking we're trying to film a video the
thing is I was watching altered carbon
last night first episode and the dude
takes cover behind its kitchen cabinets
well guys fire high-powered rifles Evan
it's like man it was some bulletproof
cabinets and then got me thinking about
all the things that Hollywood gets wrong
with guns they get it wrong so many
times and sorry we've done a lot of
videos of guns we film airsoft guns a
series with blank firing guns that's
battlefield Rush and we got out we shot
real guns a whole bunch we've run the
whole gamut from crappy fake plastic
guns to the real deal and everything in
between you've gotten something right
we've gotten something's wrong but I
want to make a video ranting about
Hollywood because that's a lot of fun to
do understanding the things that
Hollywood gets wrong about guns comes
down to understanding mechanics and how
they actually work the physics how the
bullets fly and how the gun actually
functions with like expanding gasses and
pieces of metal and all that kind of
stuff when you shoot a gun the recoil
right it kicks back it's not because the
slide moves back it's not because of the
expanding gases that's because of
Newton's law of physics for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
if you take a little piece of metal and
you accelerate it like Mach 1 or Mach 2
or I don't know how fast this particular
imaginary gun you're shooting it's
bullet let's just say you Mach 2 you
accelerate it to Mach 2 well that's a
lot of force kicking back in the other
direction and that's really what's
causing your gun to kick up and you can
see the difference if you watch
somebody's shooting a pistol out of
pistol range you'll see how much it
kicks versus how much epistle kicks in a
movie where they're using blanks for
example in the matrix he's firing two
machineguns
one-handed there's my big dick dick dick
dick getting a little bit of kick from
the expanding gases of the blanks but
not nearly as much kick as you get in
real life those things like dried up
into the air if you try to shoot real
bullets out of those but he is the one
so whatever Sam has an interesting story
actually about sound
if somebody's more than say like 200
meters away from you and they shoot at
you you'll actually see the muzzle flash
first then you'll hear the crack of the
bullet flying by because the bullets
traveling faster than the speed of sound
and then you hear the bang of the gun
so it's flash correct bang like that
really weird
no one ever mixes there something like
that they always get it wrong in fact we
have a sieve at the end of Rush where
there's a sniper taking shots somebody
Sam had to go into the sound booth
himself and do the sound himself Jack
Lee maybe we should go ask Sam about
that experience real quick I think it'd
be really fun to tell me how that works
and how movies get that wrong oh boy I
okay well first I'll I still have issues
with that scene it was like super rushed
when you filmed it not rushed hot it's
it's it's littered with many issues and
so I'd say from a visual standpoint it's
not my finest work but from an audio
standpoint I'd say it is I actually did
the sound design for that scene as well
as basically every other action scene in
that series
Karina
[Music]
here's how that works when you're doing
sniper fire basically you're taking that
same concept of rolling thunder and
applying it to sniper rifles the bullet
is traveling faster than the sound of
the rifle when you're approaching a
sniper rifle scene where people are
fighting with sniper rifles people are
not gonna shoot their guns a lot you got
to approach it with a way beef ins up
your sound you have to like make more
with less so to speak a really good way
to do that is to get really nerdy with
the physics of firing a sniper rifle at
great distances the bullets generally
travel much faster than the actual sound
of the gunshot when heard or seen at a
distance so rather than just having a
scene where the gun goes bang hit like
that you actually have a scene where it
goes like this
hit bang weird so it's like the gun
shoots silently in the distance that you
see a muzzle flash in the distance you
see a student you see the thing get hit
and then suddenly you hear like it's
almost like rolling thunder' so now
instead of just like one moment of
gunfire you're technically getting like
three you're getting the original
gunshot you're getting the bullet impact
incoming hit whizzed ricochet all that
stuff and then if you should edit your
scene right you get to also have that of
the gun firing in the distance as well
kind of takes this one singular moment
gonna spreads it out into this huge
meaty chunk I think nerd again of this
stuff makes the action more interesting
because suddenly things don't work the
way you're used to seeing the more them
I guess the closer to realism you get
the further away you get from like the
Hollywood approach all I would approach
kind of land at this point because it's
so overdone necessity is probably the
first thing in a sense that for the sake
of certain scenes and narratives and
storytelling technical physical aspects
of firearms into action and nerding out
it's really not applicable
doesn't really apply it doesn't make
this seem better sometimes you just want
your here to walk in and shoot
everything and walk out unscathed
because the point is this guy's a hero
not here's how a gun works
talking about suppressors they get that
at all I'm call suppressor not a
silencer because there's nothing that
silences sound to not only mitigate the
muzzle flash but to suppress the sound
of John wick to where they're walking
like people just walking as if they
don't hear it's like that would be so
loud but movies and always taught me
that like suppressors were for stealth
but in reality is for your hearing yeah
so you can be in like an urban situation
or inside maybe without earplugs and not
completely decimated years or the other
civilians that are around you there are
teammates or they're walking by this if
you're shooting right next to a guy you
know below as eardrums out with a
regular gun which also calls it like in
all shows and all like movies and stuff
people are shooting guns without hearing
protection especially cop shows like
your ear so he rings so hard like you
never see a movie where like an action
here I was like before he goes and he's
like yeah he should know there's a lot
of things that get wrong one thing I
really like is and they did in the
matrix - it's like they'll slow down the
action there'll be like half of the
shots are like real-time other shots are
like 30 frames a second and then other
shots are like 48 and they blend it
perfectly together so it actually feels
like it's like whoa I could see like
that little piece just a little slower
because it's kind of fast you know or
like John Woo he'll like play the same
shot three times from different angles
like I love I love that I think it like
it's such a cool piece a movie or
somebody like taking cover behind like a
cabinet and it's like stopping all the
bullets from hitting them III think that
hard for does that
you know like tables and stop it like we
have been cardboard impact of cool
reloads in the factory exactly changes
within a cage I think the worst thing in
Hollywood movies I mean I don't really
nitpicky when it comes with sunderson
Joe in the movie but if I weren't a
nitpick they would shoot off like 16 17
rounds how is this guy still shooting
without our reloading so everything
wrong with guns in Hollywood we're
acting the gun to mean you're you're
serious and you mean business in the gun
pointed at somebody and they react the
gun either a bullet should pop out when
that happens or just when they're
pointing an empty gun at the person
until you're active
holding the hammer back kind of makes
sense though it makes it easier to pull
the trigger you pull the hammer back
that joy means that your trigger pull is
not as heavy loudness cones are super
loud even with suppressors they're still
loud jams never happen
reloading never happened if I kind of
get reloading but John wick - got that
right they got a lot of reloading in
there crazy though I feel like in
today's like society with videogames
like most people have a pretty good
education as far as like how to use a
firearm like what the firearms do
wouldn't you say so
yeah but the biggest fault of video
games they teach you that reloading your
gun like like let's say you have 100
bullets and I have a 30 round mag in a
cute 5 so got 25 left reload now I've
got 95 bullets and most really happening
is you're throwing away those 25 bullets
and then man how the bullet just
magically going that's why you should
play tarkoff guns don't ever kick back
in movies like they do in real life well
if you need using blanks you only have
the expanding gases of the blank to
cause kickback which is a lot less than
if you're actually moving a piece of
mass in one direction which causes the
mass of the gun to move in the opposite
direction using air softens even weaker
Sparky the gun guy I'll rush the gas the
expanding gas from the sniper rifles
especially coming out the side like you
didn't make sure it's clear you can't
just put a camera off to the side of the
gun
oh yes it'll break the lens yeah people
don't be suddenly died from getting shot
you must of course a shot in a very
vital spot or you can get shot in the
heart and you can still run for a block
grandpa was actually in a bank robbery
not the robber he was in the bank when
it was robbed so the robber put
everybody into the vault and then locked
the vault and then
you know grabbed a stuffing left a cop
was there and shot him and you shot him
in the heart
the the robber and the I ran for another
two blocks before he dropped apparently
my grandpa has the bullet by the way
that's what my family's told me bullet
penetration that wouldn't be a hassle
though for like yeah yeah you do like
try to do a real bullet penetration your
hero would never be able to take cover
anywhere you cannot hide behind a wooden
table you can not hide behind cabinets
messes and a card or you cannot hide
behind a cardboard drywall doesn't work
either yeah they're shooting at 5 5 6 or
a what 7 6 - dude yeah they will rip
through those doors like like paper
they got riding the matrix though and
Morpheus is running and the agents
shooting through the wall and I love ya
that's a smart move oh yeah that's right
bullets don't penetrate water the only
would penetrate like this far it's kind
of crazy yeah whenever is like getting
killed in the water you'd be totally
fine
movies were like you know the hero jumps
into the water yeah so guys were getting
shot at jump in the water go down a
little bit you'll be a-ok now is they
have bow and arrow you're [ __ ]
hey just a quick reminder we are judging
the light dislocation film festival by
aperture do you want to know more about
it or take part in it click the link in
the description below
yes I'm making a potato and turning it
into a camera making a potato I'm
carving a potato into a camera I didn't
make a potato